English German Italian Spanish Dutch
Hungarian Romanian and polish
the coordinators have decided to
organize this
meeting in a hybrid format exceptionally
and I would say that the participation
online does not guarantee that you will
be interpreted today so if you speak
remotely you will be requested to do so
in English the list of speakers has been
drawn up by the chair the secretary will
help the chair to prepare the list of
speakers so you are invited to raise
your hand if you would like to take the
floor
colleagues you have the mission reports
so the mission to Paris and to Riga in
your file if you do not have any
comments before tomorrow at 10 AM they
shall be deemed adopted
a delegation of our special committee
went to the European Center of
Excellence for the fight against hybrid
threats the hybrid Coe in Helsinki on
the 7th to the 8th of September the
delegation attended the reception for
the fifth anniversary of the center and
there were several high-level meetings
with experts at the center who are
playing a key role in boosting EU
capacities to fight
hybrid threats the four-member
delegation included Rafael gluxman who
was the head of the delegation Mr
Vladimir bilchik for the Epp Mr Sandra
Caliente for the Epp and Mrs pagosunda
for renew
and we also went to Australia last year
there were four members who went on that
delegation Mr glucksman who was the head
of the delegation Mrs Lima from the Epp
Mr Andres shida from s d and Mr kirstos
for renew the delegation went to
Canberra and Melbourne and met several
government Representatives including the
vice prime minister the defense minister
General Parker and the minister for the
home Affairs the mission
let us analyze the implementation of
Australian legislation aimed at
protecting the country from foreign
interference and Chinese interference in
particular those laws and institutions
responsible for applying that law in
Australia are draw for this fight
against foreigns our mission let us
understand what could be applied in
Europe or not cooperation with
democracies facing the same risks as us
is a key part of our mandate and we will
continue to do that work after Taiwan
after the USA and Australia we will be
looking at this institutional Network
fighting against all forms of foreign
interference
colleagues
this is a crucial Turning Point winter
is coming and the energy crisis is with
us and there are price Rises the EU
opinion is looking at supporting Ukraine
Russian disinformation had an impact at
the start of the war and it is having
even more of an echo now and we depend
on the networks in our countries there
have been demonstrations against
inflation and some of them were recently
exploited encouraged or even initiated
by people who had connections with the
Russian system unable to win the
military one Ukraine Putin is going to
try to win politically here with us by
subverting our public debate and by
imposing defeatist narrative
stories we cannot simply let that happen
we cannot give him when it comes to
information the victory that the
ukrainians are refusing to give him in
military terms so it is high time that
our special committee looks at these
campaigns run by Russia to manipulate
information about the war in Ukraine
given the importance of this subject and
the challenge I am pleased to welcome
the effort and study committees and the
delegation for Parliament cooperation EU
Russia I would like to welcome Mr washy
who is the vice chair of the effort
committee and who is the chair of the
delegation to the EU Ukraine
parliamentary delegation Association and
I'd like to welcome Mrs Natalie Lazo as
well who is the chair of the city
subcommittee and Mr richardski who is
the chair of the Parliamentary
cooperation committee for EU Russia Mr
washkovski you have the flow for three
minutes
foreign
first of all let me thank the chair of
the special committee on four
interference
in all democracy process in European
including this information Mr Rafael
gisma for his kind vegetation to attend
this promising here as we all know
Russia is a major threat to European
security and the stability of our
democracy
obviously Russia is the first and
foremost a military threat as it is
brutal war of aggression against Ukraine
clearly shows
Russia is also a threat in a more subtle
but still very dangerous right as he
tries to infiltrate and influence our
Democratic process and our media
indeed
in the past 10 years maybe more have we
witnessed a massive increase in
interferences from Grammy spousal media
Outlets agents and trolls Amy I'm at
influencing the internal affairs of
democracy around the globe the crime is
investing huge resources to pursue
such a policy as recent U.S security
agency's reports showed
against the background of the Russian
barbaric War aggression against Ukraine
those interferences have become even
more blatant spread to Regions
previously unaffected such as maina
region Africa and Latin in America
they need to counter those attempts and
prevent Russia from speaking its
fasteneratives has therefore become an
absolute
urgency
unfortunately however the gap between
the resources employed by Russia and
those mobilized by the European Union to
respond to it Irma is relevant moreover
the your policy remains to a large
extent reactive
and this has obvious pitfalls in the
current situation for example a few
months ago the EU impose a ban on the
broadcasting activities of
sporting and Russia today because of the
disinformation activities
however the EU band did not go far
enough and as a course of Christ is
another crime in bike media continue to
spread lies online under social media
therefore jeopardizing
EU sanctions with all that in mind
might might imagine this year our
Parliament call for more ambitious
action to stop Russia this information
interior we ask for specific regulation
and actions to be taken to oblige online
platforms to do their part to reduce
information manipulation and
interference for instance by using
labels that indicated through authors
behind accounts the limiting the reach
of accounts regular use to spread this
information
suspending and if necessary
deleting accounts
used for coordinating interface
campaigns we also ask your European
institution and member states to fill
gaps and loopholes encouraged Legacy
legislation and policies at the European
Union and National level I'm a detecting
preventing and combating for
interference
we also called on the European Union to
raise awareness of the sheerness of the
threat posed by foreign
how to retire on regimes another
malicious actors as well as the lack of
appropriate and sufficient standards and
measures to identified and respond to
acts of for interference we look forward
to commission proposing a multi-layer
coordinated and cross-sector strategy as
well as other Christ Financial Resources
aimed at equipping the European Union
and the members they with appropriate
foresight and resilience policies to the
veterans tools
above all Europeans unions foreign
Services the information and strategy
communication units must be
substantially strengthened to conclude
as you rightly said back in March we
need political college and lucidity also
named leadership that's what we were
lacking at what we need now
with all that him I would like to give
what our experts think about the
achievements and pitfalls of the
measures adopted by the European to
counter Russian interference attempts
and understand how to improve or expand
them based on our March 2022
recommendations I thank you chair
thank you very much Mrs lawyer you
online and you have the floor
merci Mr President thank you Rafael once
more in G2 and say they have decided to
have this hearing jointly as indeed this
information is fully part of Russia's
War efforts
actually the issue is new and Russia
started to Target Ukraine using Intel
earlier propaganda and disinformation
since 2014. we hardly paid attention
then except when the crash of amh 17
flight took place and triggered
countless Russian efforts to try to deny
responsibility
malicious misinformation campaigns
originating from Russia towards Ukraine
are not a new topic either
as they have been continuously going on
for years
what is unprecedented though is the
breadth and depth of covert propaganda
campaigns designed at deterring European
public opinions to support Ukraine and
to accept the increase in sanctions
towards Russia
we just learned about the doppelganger
influence operation which was debunked
both by eudism full Lab and by meta
from May 2022 Russia used clones of
authentic European media such as the
guardian vaminud build or answer to try
to discredit Ukraine
and spread false narrative about the
consequences of the sanctions on
European citizens
good news is that it was debunked
bad news is that it was possible
and that the culprits were not clearly
identified
we probably have to better regulate the
domain name industry and Foster
cooperation between State institutions
platforms researchers and ngos so that
they can really join forces prevent
expose encounter such operations
generally speaking we have to admit that
suspending RT and Sputnik in Europe was
only addressing the tip of the iceberg
not only are accesses to RT and Sputnik
still available in Europe
but the propaganda machine of the
Kremlin found new covet ways to spread
this information through numerous
proxies
one they question the efficiency of
propaganda efforts at the moment where
there is still strong support from
Ukrainian European public opinions
I would not to be too optimistic though
considering that the first purpose of
Russia propaganda isn't necessarily to
be trusted
but to create blurred perception of
facts and to level the narratives
we just witnessed the denial by Moscow
of any responsibility in the sabotage of
no stream pipelines and one must admit
that the Russian narrative has a strong
echo in our societies
I would also like to underline the
consequences of Russian disinformation
efforts outside Europe
every single mission of our parliament
in Africa the Middle East or Latin
America is an occasion to witness the
efficiency of Russian propaganda and to
deploy the weakness of our strategic
communication
despite regular calls from India and
City we haven't seen yet any significant
change in the way we reach public
opinions outside the EU
at this very moment of the return of war
in Europe
this business as usual approach is
especially worrying
one last word but it is probably not the
least important
due to the absence of media freedom in
Russia
and to the closure of Western media
sources decided by the Kremlin
it is quite difficult to reach out to
Russian audience and succeed in having
our positions heard
I sincerely regret that we couldn't have
a discussion today with Dimitri muratov
and I'd like to express my deepest
admiration for his courage and his work
I would welcome any suggestions on
creative ways to maintain contact with
the Russian audience
including through the numerous Russian
citizens who have fled Russia since
February 24th and even in the last few
days thank you
merci beaucoup
thank you Mr schnecki you have the floor
thank you Mr luxman uh for giving me the
floor and especially for associating uh
our delegation to this very important
especially now hearing this special
committee is doing an essential job by
contributing to expose the Kremlin
tactics of propaganda and Derby to
counter Russian narratives it was set
before bust this information is a
crucial element of this war in Eastern
Europe
uh and it's directed not only to the
audience at home but also to secure
Elias
on all continents and so division in
Europe and influence voters choices
regarding Putin's audience at home we
may well be living at turning point
the announcement of the mobilization a
week ago sent a shock wave through the
Russian Federation this is a country
which has been fed for over a decade
with heavy propaganda
a country in which a large majority of
the population had accepted to test its
social contract given put in carte
blanche in return for guarantees of
economic and social stability yesterday
I was culturing the screening of the
documentary on Alexi navalny with vice
president Parliament Heidi hautala it
was striking to listen to Mr volkov his
chief of staff saying the mobilization
announcement has shocked in such a way
that
what he called the sleepers who accepted
the social contract are now waking up
those people who represented 60 70
percent of the population are starting
to ask questions and are looking for
answers
they are not ready to take the liars and
the mites any longer
they can't return a blind a because
every single family in Russia is now
concerned by the war
uh finally speaking
this is why it may now be time to step
up our efforts to reach out to Russian
Civil Society with those answers we must
be prepared for the counter narrative
war with strong messages with the true
on the war in Ukraine the massacres that
farce protects on the uh on Dennis
vacations we must also help the diaspora
in Europe to spread them
as they have direct and trustworthy
contacts with their relatives in the
country I will finish now and let me say
that I very much look forward to
contributions of our eminent guests and
to debate thank you Mr chairman
thank you
mercies
thank you
but now like to welcome our experts
for medical reasons Mr muratov is not
able to attend today's meeting
we wish him a speedy recovery and we
hope to be able to welcome him to uh one
of our meetings very soon
and Ms rudenko for
Urgent personal reasons is also not able
to attend the meeting
so our next guest is Mr Sheldon from
bellingcat
Mr Sheldon you have a proven track
record in research and verification of
Open Source on the war in Ukraine you
have the floor for 10 minutes
thank you so much
um yes so uh first I want to just for
for a little bit of context I want to go
through
um a bit of my background I have been
working on
um Russia's war in Ukraine uh since for
about five years now so primarily in the
past that meant that my geographical
Focus was in the dunbas and then
unfortunately in in February this year
it
expanded uh greatly
and so my my work involves
um
going through Visual Evidence uh
digitally primarily
um primarily digital evidence
um
and and determining
um truths
um through this uh online evidence
and so
um obviously that is a very valuable
tool in combating disinformation
and so
with with that in mind I'm going to go
through
um kind of a segmented uh talk here
about
um some some challenges that I identify
with you know with respect to Russian
disinformation
um and then also some some sort of
trends that I'm noticing in Russian
disinformation
since
um uh since February this year
so
um
I find that when we talk about
Russian disinformation it's often uh
difficult to discern
what exactly we're we're talking about
um you know are we talking about Russian
State origin disinformation or are we
talking about pro-russian disinformation
um
or you know just Russian or just
disinformation emanating from Russia as
as a whole
um and so there
one can debate how important that that
distinction really is
um
but the the reality is that today there
there are so many Anonymous media uh
social media Outlets
um
and and other
um
media forms that that uh disinformation
or or um uh propaganda in in favor of
Russia um emanate from
and so
determining ownership can can be
incredibly difficult
um it's possible in in many cases but it
requires a tremendous amount of work
um
and so even so when we have these sort
of this dichotomy between
um Russian Russians you know State
origin disinformation or propaganda and
also
um just you know Russian government
sympathetic
um
origin uh propaganda or or
disinformation we have to
acknowledge to some degree that they
exist Within
the same ecosystem of
of um of shared ideas and and will often
riff off of each other
um
and share the same
um the same uh disinformation narratives
or or propaganda narratives
um in in order to sort of to strengthen
um
their their position uh jointly that
that's of course not to to imply a um
any sort of coordinated coordinated
effort in in a lot of cases that's of
course on a case-by-case base basis but
that's sort of how it works is that
and a narrative or or a piece of
disinformation can can either
um
can can in a lot of cases
originate from a third party uh so
whether that be a private social media
account whether that be
um some sort of a media Outlet Fringe
media
and it can then be laundered through
um Russian Russian um State
media Outlets whether that be actual
State Media or
or um you know Russian um Embassy
accounts especially on on Twitter we see
that a lot
um
and so
and and that's sort of
kind of feeds into to another thing that
that I consider a challenge
um is is to sing distinguishing between
disinformation and adversarial or or
propaganda or maybe even you can
consider Russia biased narratives and or
misinformation
um
all very different things
and and from from a read specific
perspective it might not
um matter a whole lot uh from from my
perspective as as a researcher who often
will try to
determine
um what what is true what is untrue
um
and and what what could the intent
behind this be is this an uh purposeful
Act of disinformation or is it
um or is it misinformation that was
was you know shared incomplete or or
untrue information
um
just by happenstance
it that that's sort of that's a hard
thing to to do and it and it's a
difficult line to tread
um
what is you know what is disinformation
misinformation
um often comes down to to judging intent
um and so
yeah
um
another thing that that I think is is
important to bear in mind is that at
least in my experience
um my observations uh I believe that a
large bulk of if if not most of Russian
disinformation is incented for a
domestic audience
so in the lead up to the war we saw a
lot of outright disinformation
fabricated events
um being being put together for
um Fringe Media or for
um
social media to then be laundered
through State media to be shown to
Russian citizens to to help justify the
war and and to sort of prime them for
the war
and
you know a lot of this this
disinformation now
we'll we'll see to more than
justify them War by sort of kinetic
means we'll we'll try to dehumanize
ukrainians
um call them Nazis uh question the
existence of a Ukrainian State
um and and so fear around NATO
so what with all this in mind
um what what disinformation
um most targets
citizens of the European Union or or
targets or audiences I'm sorry outside
of Russia
um
I kind of I like to view this through
two different lenses
um one is on the sort of more strategic
level of disinformation and and hostile
narratives
um and the other is on the Tactical
level
so what I mean by that is is um
strategic level being much more uh
long-sided uh incentive to have sort of
a real effect
um and and tactical level being more um
incident response based and um
and and seeking to to sow doubt around
specific events
um
so on on sort of this broader
um strategic level of disinformation uh
we we see that you know these
information operations or Russian
disinformation would would
would seek to soften a western response
to to Russian kinetic action
um you know the Russian war against
Ukraine
um
and so this this will often come in the
form of
um disinformation targeting arm supplies
for example so focus on
um dark web markets
um focus on on weapons
um
which present a challenge to Russia that
the West is supplying to to Ukraine so
that would be javelin's U.S produced
javelins uh Swedish produced ac4s uh
French produced uh Caesar artillery
pieces
and so the the aim is to paint Ukraine
as as a corrupt unreliable
um
country which which could could pose a
security threat to the West
um
and
um
which you know of course none of these
were true or at least unverifiable uh
these narratives
um because of the the the sourcing that
they had
um
and so along this line of painting
Ukraine as as sort of a danger
um disinformation will also Target uh
Ukrainian diaspora or Ukrainian refugees
um in
um where you know wherever they are
particularly in Poland
um and so these will often um
these narratives will often attempt to
paint
um ukrainians as ungrateful
um to to the help that they're receiving
or or even create the impression that
ukrainians intend to take over uh the
the country that they they have fled to
um and and that kind of
um
narrative is is backed up by forged
documents and and the like
um
and so on the more more incident
response level uh disinformation
will incense is so confusion around
specific events
um that that might make Russia look bad
or or take advantage of
um
events where whichever disinformation
actor might feel like this could make
Ukraine look bad so this would be denial
of air strikes um saying that Ukraine
bombs itself you know make Ukraine
looking competent
um
claiming that atrocities were staged by
Ukraine is a recent example that we've
been dealing with
um co-opting
um a greater Trend or a more interesting
Trend that we've noticed recently is
co-opting modern fact-checking style
reporting
um
with this sort of Mal intent
um
so so using the style of reporting that
a lot of Western fact-checking
um
the organizations will use but for
disinformation and so
um
this will create the impression of a
legitimate fact-checking service
um
and and kind of help
give give Credence to these
disinformation narratives
um
and help them appear apolitical while
they're actually deeply biased towards
Russia and so
in the immediate term that that would
kind of um
the danger there is that it it could
help convince especially because a lot
of the or the bigger ones of these are
also available in English language
um
the immediate term uh danger is that of
course
um it could help confuse uh Western
audiences about what's actually
happening on the ground but over time it
can also serve to sort of a road trust
and um in in these fact-checking methods
um
that that um that that we have
um
so that when people see a fact checking
order organ they'll say okay well we
have
a fact checking organ on
on one side saying one thing and we have
another another in fact I can learn on
the other side saying another thing are
these you know fact checking
organizations really reliable
um it really just seems that they're
subjective and so it's
that that's sort of one of the bigger
dangers that I'm that I'm noticing out
of uh out of Ukraine and and some of my
former colleagues at the digital
forensic research lab have done some
really good research on that so that's
it for me
Mercy
thank you very much
I'm now going to give the floor to Mr
Ross Burley who's the co-founder and
executive director of the center for
information resilience which is an
independent organization which is
fighting against disinformation Mr
Burley you have the floor
good morning and and many thanks for for
having me
um while while I'm delighted this
committee is undertaking hearings and
doing excellent work it is bittersweet
countries across the globe and
especially within Europe should have
recognized the threat of disinformation
to us all
um
also for not recognizing sooner that the
for the the Putin regime for what it is
it is a malign repugnant malevolent
force it has murdered dozens of
journalists and opposition leaders
its leader is a former KGB agent with no
regard for the rule of law or
International laws
the regime has deployed chemical and
radiological weapons under one of
Europe's great cities it has a next
Crimea it plans to Annex more as we
speak
it invaded Georgia
ironically given its false charges
around neo-nazis in Ukraine Russia has
done more to support the far right in
Europe than any other country since the
1940s which is not surprising given
Putin's own background in the KGB and
his alleged activities in Eastern
Germany
oh
Russia has weaponized information it has
attacked with relish
the very notion of Truth itself
Russian disinformation is
almost like a nightmare it takes the
very worst of us the fishes in our
society our worst beliefs and our
deepest fears and it amplifies them
through gamed social media algorithms
fear of the other fear of change
suspicion of authority the belief and
conspiracy where none exists rejection
rational thought and objectivity
Russian disinformation seeks to destroy
our trust in government and most of all
destroy our belief in democracy
Putin and his regime are terrified of
true democracy they always have been
so they weaponize social media
the army of useful idiots the lacks
legislation the overworked and
understaffed and underfunded
intelligence Services the lack of cross
border integrated Integrations and
working together
to attack and distort our very belief in
truth
in Ukraine we've seen their tactics
firsthand complete denials what about
ISM the deployment of chaos and what
about systems by their officials and
network of embassies the denials even on
the eve of War itself that it was about
to happen
the as Michael said the deployment of
fake fact Checkers such as war and fakes
that is it in itself linked to the
Russian State the activation of their
top-down influence campaigns attempting
to push narratives around Nazis around
zelinski NATO Fighters all churned
through the machines of Arty Sputnik and
others
in Ukraine as in other places Russia
deploys its disinformation machine is
most successful tactics are not about
creating truth I.E using fakes but
distorting truth and I'll give an
example this is an example of creating
truth in the beginning of the war with
Russia desperately trying to justify its
actions it staged a car bomb attack in
Donetsk claims that the it was a
Ukrainian separate the ukrainians who
committed it
how do we know it was false in the
pictures posted on telegram we were able
to see the bodies of the alleged victims
they were cadavers we could see the
surgical Cuts in the craniums
yet this Ukraine Ukrainian atrocity was
reported far and wide on on social media
and pushed through Telegram and pushed
through all sorts of places where
Russian has those Russia has those
disinformation apparatus
but recently I'll give an example to
distort the truth the Russian Embassy in
South Africa deploying anti-british
messages around colonialism using the
historical truth around the legacy of
Empire to emotionally manipulate South
Africans to paint what was happening in
Ukraine as Colonial efforts distorting
that grain of Truth
the consequences for for for you as
policy makers is that we can't debunk
emotion we can't fact check it which is
why so many of the most effective
disinformation campaigns deploy emotion
at their heart and we see this in
cross-cutting narratives in this war
that butcher was staged bio Labs
Ukrainian war crimes that you Western
sanctions are to blame for the energy
crisis rather than the Russia itself the
deployment of so-called Western Fighters
all of these are absurd narratives that
use emotional manipulation to push their
readers to one with
is that true
to make them click on that link
well maybe I haven't been told the truth
what what are they hiding to feed that
human desire for excitement to reveal
hidden secrets
this is especially true when we consider
the channels Russia uses telegram has
matured in this conflict it's one of the
primary vectors it's difficult to censor
they at the moment they only generally
take down terrorist material it's
critique free you can broadcast without
comment it's driven with pro-russian
content it lies about the war with lies
about European Parliament all without
response and it poses a challenge to
Twitter meta and Google if we censor
actors and they move to other platforms
how many
temperatures
Mr Ross just press once on this big
button please
okay hopefully I'm back
yes you are back but we lost you yeah
apologies so as I was saying they're
using Reddit Rubble Odyssey getter bit
shoot and more often they're presenting
their narratives with no pushback from
from Western voices or western actors
their truth is effectively the objective
truth in these spaces
so so what can we do we know many of the
identities of the European Canadian
American and British proxies who are
deliberately spreading disinformation
who are often acting on behalf of the
Russian state so we should sanction them
we need to recognize the difference
between disinformation and influence
operations this information is just one
tentacle on the octopus Russia uses its
political financial and Military tools
to spread influence and disrupt
International Norms across the world
Mali Colombia Central African Republic I
could I could go on
we have to understand that we're not
dealing with a normal State it's been
distorted from a normal State into
effectively a mafia Network where the
spread of disinformation is just one
weapon one arrow in the quiver
in good news you have allies here
committee we are lucky here in Europe to
have a robust dedicated journalist to
expose these networks and malign
activities and they they have to be
supported in particular we have to
prevent uh vexicious legal proceedings
stopping absurd situation where the head
of where the head of the Wagner group is
able to sue the founder of bellingcat
for stating the obvious
we have the growth of Open Source
investigators and investigations
um we're joined here by Michael from
bellingcat who doing amazing work we at
CR are doing similar work and it's
pouring treacle over the Russian
disinformation efforts we know Russia
was responsible for butcher how do we
know through satellite imagery showing
the Grim growth of mass Graves through
countless videos uploaded to social
media that were able to scrape and
archive and store and verify showing
Russian troops in the area through CCTV
images through unencrypted
Communications between Russian troops
discussing what happened in the town
their lives meet the truth in open
source objective truth finally wins out
Europe should embrace the power of Open
Source crucially we can use it to hold
those responsible for war crimes to
account
platforms of course have a role to play
here we have to work more effectively
they have to work more effectively with
the media and Civil Society to give us
as researchers access to their data and
their apis so we can work together to
tackle coordinated campaigns and
influence operations and earlier on it
was mentioned the doppelganger
operation that is a really good example
of how this can work effectively in
practice
I think that's it for me I think my 10
minutes is up so I'm happy to answer any
questions that that you guys have thank
you
merci
thank you very much I'd now like to give
the floor to the members starting with
Ms kanyetti who's the repertoire for the
special committee on behalf of the EPP
um
you have the floor
thank you I hope you hear me and see me
because I am speaking from Epp study
days and I'm elected from Latvia which
is a country for years under the Russia
hybrid war and info War pressure and we
have built quite an experience I have
few questions to to our speakers they
use this info lab came out on Tuesday
with an open source investigation
exposing a russia-based influence
operation Network
that has been intentionally organized in
Europe since May the investigation
uncovered wide use of clones
of authentic media such as built and the
guardian to promote pro-russian and
anti-ukrainian narratives
it is alarming how such things have
happened under our nose
also using eu-based and legally
registrated software and the
infrastructure therefore we need to look
more carefully at the existing
legislative gaps and enforcement
mechanisms and this is something what I
intend to do in my report the core
questions are how they you could improve
our digital ecosystem and our
attribution capabilities
and then um I would like also to speak
about Ukraine since Russia in the
Russia's invasion of Ukraine several EU
member states such as the Baltic states
have taken steps to restrict access to
Russian state-sponsored and state
promoted media but could you outline
what is the situation at the EU level
and do you believe that actions at the
EU level to protect our information
space from Russian propaganda have been
sufficient
uh since Ukraine's recent successes in
the battlefield we have seen noticeable
shifts in Russian propaganda narratives
including a new narrative that Russia is
at war with the whole of NATO not just
Ukraine
do you believe this can lay ground for
further escalation of the conflict which
is the most important issue the recent
mobilization in Russia had led hundreds
of thousands of Russians to flee than a
to neighboring countries both of the EU
and Beyond in your view what added
security risks does this human mass
movement pose for the EU and how should
EU governments approach this Challenge
from a strategic Communications
perspective because for instance Baltic
states we had closed our borders and
restricted access to to our countries or
only to those who are coming for
humanitarian
needs thank you
of the floor that's it president
thank you chair
I think
that
it is important
to use this opportunity that we have to
get into this in detail and I think that
we're all aware of the need to counter
information and interference as much as
possible and so that's
why
I
was thinking
when it comes to what Sheldon was saying
that we need to really Define these and
not confuse interference or this is my
opinion at least with the freedom of
expression and freedom to criticize
Etc even when you're faced with
something as terrible as this war by
Putin and I'd be interested in asking
Michael schenden a question
about a key Point here
and about the other speaker's opinion on
this as well so how can we
look at Country
um disinformation coming from Europe
that's targeted at the Russian people
that's a key issue here so how can we
help here in Europe so not just in
Europe this is something that we have
had to think about many times before but
you've got this disinformation in
Russian so how can we help out there
if you have people who don't want to
just follow this single thought line by
Putin
I'm from common
you have the floor
for the greens
um
thank you very much
thank you very much I think it's just
incredibly difficult
dealing with such a hard and brutal uh
war of aggression and destruction of
annihilation
um it's
Russia hasn't just been doing this uh
sort of fake news campaign or hybrid
hasn't been conducting hybrid Warfare
against us since the 24th of February of
this year it's been doing it for a long
time and Russia knows our weaknesses and
knows how to exploit them very well we
can see this at various levels
and we see how difficult it is to combat
this because we've seen just how well
and efficiently a Russia conducts its
disinformation policy and I have to say
they have a lot of accomplices a lot of
supporters
in various member states which of course
complicates matters even further for
example yesterday I heard that at the
U.N General Assembly
where you could
assume that Russia would be isolated
it's not the fact the Bulgarian
delegation made a
a room available
um
to to the Russian delegation to address
the
assembly so it has some willing helpers
um
in in spreading their messages in the
western Balkans and Hungary in the EU
is
still loyal to Russia a political level
so there are plenty of
weak points which Russia is exploiting
many channels that it can use in order
to undermine uh
democracies and as Mr Ross
said
giving the example of this South African
um
incident where attempts were made to
stir up resentment about colonialism and
I saw this in Iraq the Iraqi population
uh of course felt that the sanctions
against them uh
were a very negative thing and now
they're feeling sympathetic to to Russia
although they don't really know what's
at stake in this conflict
and the Russians are exploiting that and
we haven't really seen any sign of how
we are going to combat this in uh in
Africa in South Africa in the Middle
East how we are going to combat this
disinformation campaign how we can sort
of debunk it uh
and when when Partners in this campaign
and I don't think we're going to secede
in the long term if we just say we have
a better system we we have better
answers I think we have to conduct an
active
policy and deploy more man and woman
power
um to get our message across we are just
at the beginning here and
the recommendations in our report and Ms
Kanye's report absolutely have to be
implemented to go about this thank you
merci is thank you can I remind you
that Mr Gunner is with us on behalf of
the external Action Service who will be
able to answer some of the questions
that are being raised by members
and we are delighted to have you with us
Mr Gainer
but now I'd like to give the floor
to Mr Fest for the ID group
thank you very much
I'm not really sure which expert will
answer me but I think you should follow
the principle of following the money
Chancellor
Merkel in 2019 said at the Munich
security conference that she had proof
she had evidence that
Russia was providing financial support
to many
um climate activists and Miss Hillary
Clinton said the same so I wonder
whether there is any information
available as to how Financial flows have
gone from Russia to left-wing
organizations or right-wing
organizations so it doesn't really
matter
but uh is there any you know hard
evidence of this
Mercy thank you ECR now Mr Tech you have
the flu
thank you very much chairman
and thank you
to everybody who's been giving us
information
this massive disinformation campaign
from Russia has to be combated it's been
going on for many years we've heard
about this from many
organizations and Mr Ross talked about
the extreme right to supporting this but
in in Spain it's clear that
Russia has financed
various organizations
um
also in Cuba in Venezuela uh there's
also a extreme left
organizations that are providing a
platform for continuous and permanent
false information this is the case in
Spain and that has
made it possible for an extreme left
um
party to form a government
with the social Democrats in Spain so I
think it's
very important that we look at that
aspect
um
and when for years you know Euro News
has been saying that Miss Maloney has a
pro-russian stance when it's radically
and obviously not true
and and she's been making this clear
both before and after the elections
we also need to ask ourselves
about this misinformation uh
so it's not just
Russia Russia is investing as much as
much in the extreme leftist information
as in the extreme right disinformation
so we could we should keep an eye on
that too
thank you well of course sometimes
people's positions change over time and
a leader might take one position uh at
one time and then have another another
time Miss Davey for the left group very
much chair and thanks to all our
speakers I would hope that well we
obviously all know that truth is the
first casualty of war and I'm assuming
that the panel would agree with me that
that relates to all sides in a conflict
not just the Russian one but the NATO
Ukraine one as well
um I was very interested in all of the
contributions maybe just to take up a
couple of points on the Michael at the
start made a point about
um the propaganda being aimed at a
domestic audience in Russia to provide a
basis for the war and one of the points
he made was that the way of doing that
is to call ukrainians Nazis and I think
our last speaker said the saying that
they were pushing this Nazi narrative
but I'd just like to explore that a
little bit because obviously they claim
by Putin that Ukraine is a fascist State
and has to be denastified as patently
appalling and wrong and nobody would
agree with that but we risk going to The
Other Extreme and saying oh forgetting
all the facts that are out there that
there is a sizable not Nazi and fascist
influence in Ukraine and we don't do
ourselves any favor by denying that and
maybe ask Michael to talk about the
report by his colleague Michael Colburn
from bellingcast hardly a Russian outfit
by any means and who wrote the report
from the fires of War Ukraine's as of
movement and the global fire right where
he makes the point that as of as a
multi-pronged heterogeneous far-right
social movement which exerts influence
on Ukrainian politics and Society
despite its numbers and deals with the
fact that they've been integrated into
the Ukrainian armed forces have a major
influence in that state so I'd like some
commentary on that point if I could the
point was made as well about
um and it was put down as disinformation
painting Ukraine as a corrupt and
unreliable Society by dealing with stuff
of cell and some of the arms that they
got and all that but the U.S
Administration itself has acknowledged
that the Weaponry which has gone into
Ukraine is unaccountable and has gone
far flown so that's just a fact and in
terms of corruption we don't have to
look very far our own European Court of
Auditors this time last year did a
damning report on the mass of corruption
that exists in Ukraine that's not in any
way to say the war is Justified because
of course the war is not justified but
we don't do ourselves any favors by sort
of counteract and Russia propaganda with
our own propaganda so I'd like maybe a
bit of that and then just two quick
things two colleagues and some
colleagues made the point but I'd like
to know the point on on the panel like
do you not think like that the people
who live in Africa and in Latin America
they're not ages who are just being
sucked in by Russian propaganda they're
societies who felt the brunt of U.S
imperialism and interference and
sanctions and their own people dying and
nobody in the rest of the world given a
damn about them frankly so it is
understandable if you like that they'd
have a bit of a reaction in this
situation it's not that they support the
war or anything like that but they're
certainly not going to buy into a NATO
narrative so I'd like commentary and
last point I suppose is how do people on
the panel think the war is going to be
stopped if nobody talks to Russia I mean
is that not the way in which we will
resolve it and I mean nobody brought up
the Nordstrom 2 issue but I mean like
what's the panel's opinion on that I
mean what in God's name interest would
Russia have in interfering with North
stream too the only beneficiaries of
that are the USA as far as I'm concerned
I don't know who carried it out but it
should be investigated and do the panel
I think that investigation means
independent investigation not an
investigation by some of the people who
serve to benefit by breaking the link
between Russia and Europe enormously and
leave us in Hawk to us LNG for the rest
of our lives I don't know who did it but
I'd like an actual independent
investigation into it thanks
well I'm not sure our panelists uh
in possession of direct Intelligence on
on on the type issue uh because they are
here to speak about this information so
your last question I'm not sure they
will have a clear response to to your
concerns but uh thank you for your
questions uh Mr bilchik for the Epp you
have the floor
thank you very much thank you very much
chair and uh hopefully connection works
and uh thank you very much for this
opportunity uh this is an extremely
important topic and I'm very pleased
that we are having it today because
to truly help Ukraine win this War uh we
not only have to make sure that Ukraine
has full control of its territorial
sovereignty but we also must help
Ukraine and actually be on Ukraine uh
help free people's minds from pervasive
Russian propaganda which has been a part
of this war efforts not just for the
past months since 24th of February uh
unfortunately it's been around for years
and
um the problem we are facing across the
European Union too is that we've been
extremely extremely
um unfocused when it comes to the
problem that Russia has created uh not
just um in and across Ukraine but beyond
and in Europe we have to fight back and
this is why it's extremely important to
hear firsthand also from our colleagues
and friends in Ukraine and from those
who have been focusing uh on the problem
of the Russian disinformation
um I do have several questions I want to
race in this regard I'd like to ask
on this problem of this information and
what role is being played is special
when it comes to Ukraine and the
Ukrainian people what role is there for
traditional media and Motorola is there
for the online space in particular for
the for the platforms
how much have the Russian disinformation
captured the online space as opposed how
much has it have been able to capture
the
media which we know under the
title or adjective of a traditional and
what are the different tactics we could
deploy to help Ukraine fight this but
what are also different tactics people
deploy to fight this Beyond including in
our own EU space and the second issue I
want to raise is that but one of the
problems we are facing in trying to win
the people's minds is not only
um in and around Ukraine but also across
the European Union Russia has been very
effective and we have to be doubly
effective in trying to free people's
minds and I'd like to hear the panelists
comment a bit more which are the weakest
points when it comes to the European
space both the EU but also the accession
countries where do we see we should
focus on uh in trying to stop the spread
of Russian propaganda
which of course doesn't know borders
because information doesn't really know
borders and it spreads very freely these
days
I'm grateful to be able to connect to
this meeting uh from Belgrade today
where I'm on a mission and I'm grateful
we have this hybrid connection but this
is precisely what I'm talking about when
it comes to uh trying to fight the
spread of Russian propaganda it's not
just about bringing it in and across
Ukraine we must we must go beyond to
make sure that Ukraine is free long
after uh winning this war which I very
much hope and which will be the case
soon so thank you very much for this
great opportunity and there is no shade
of prey in this um I think it's very
clear who the culprit is who the guilty
side is and who the victim is and we
have to stand by our Ukrainian friends
and partners and we will do so
um unquestionably as we have done so so
far in the European Parliament thank you
very much and I look forward to your
answers
thank you Mr bilchik now Mr shimoshevich
for the snd group you have the floor
um
it is true that um in Ukraine
also you can find neo-nazis
um in Poland we're very aware of this
but you have to remember that
in Democratic elections you know the
extreme writers never obtained more than
one percent so you know bringing up
these Russian lies in our debate isn't
is not helpful in Ukraine people are
being murdered women and children by the
Russians it is the Russians who are
doing this and this is the Scandal
um respecting freedom of expression in
our debate I agree with Natalie luazoa
and I won't repeat what she said but
um I just want to say that as far as I'm
concerned
what we've been seeing for a long time
now in this this information
campaign that Russia is conducting
against the Democratic societies
is
acquiring
um the dimensions of a hybrid war of
disinformation with
short-term objectives and it's easy to
understand when you look at the effects
of the war that Russia is waging
so
let's just keep a perspective who is the
victim who is the aggressor who started
the war who is responsible for this I
think that's the perspective that you
have to keep at the at the back of your
mind this is to undermine the West
in Prague yesterday that there were
more checks demonstrating than than two
weeks ago calling on the government to
change its policy against Russia and
there it was uh you know the the check
interests that were coming to the fore
and something very similar is happening
in other countries of Europe
because you know many people believe all
of the disinformation about NATO uh the
United States announces Russian
propaganda is scandalous particularly
bearing in mind that what we are
witnessing is an armed aggression and
armed invasion
and
they seem to be able to justify their
actions in certain circles so I think
it's very important to look at what is
going to be happening in the very near
future today or tomorrow Russia
um will be annexing parts of Ukraine and
then they'll claim that Ukraine is the
aggressor attacking Russian territory
and that will give Russia cat Blanche to
use
uh even more deadly weapons including
nuclear weapons so there is a genuine
threat to Security in Europe and in the
world and we have to really realize what
is happening right now and here I'm not
just speaking to the um
to the experts but also to uh
representatives of the of the commission
and other European institutions the
council as well the time has come to act
this is a historic moment our common
security is in danger thank you
thank you Mr getter for renew
able
thank you chairman I think that in our
approach to this problem
we should make a clear distinction
between various aspects
we
are confronted with uh very traditional
undertakings but of course now these
attempts are supported by new
technologies you know these are the
classical uh
efforts to misinform disinform
seeking
to make people believe in fairy tales in
uh
false information so that is that is one
weapon but then there is another weapon
in this war in this
Campaign which is
the fight for the narrative
and how we react to events and I'm
struck
by the fact that Mr Putin has got a
Kremlin spokesman Mr pishkoff
a ham to know him he's a
brilliant man and we see the damage that
he managed to do four times a day
uh Mr Putin
has a voice
and in in the best newspapers in the
best media on on the best TV programs
this gets results we here Mr peskov what
he has to say in our media and then we
note reactions from Paris Rome
Washington
Tokyo Berlin
there isn't one voice like that coming
to counter The Narrative of Mr Putin
in the same way so I think
before we get
bogged down and it is very difficult
obviously we have to combat this
narrative but in our fight against the
manipulation of information against
disinformation is
it is very difficult for us because it
would be much easier if we had a peshkov
we need one single spokesperson for the
EU
I mean that wouldn't make sense wouldn't
it the European Union as such
is committed and and we welcome that
uh to uh supporting Ukraine
so I for my part
would like the external Action Service
to have a spokesperson
whose sole task would be to communicate
on the Ukraine
War the war in Ukraine and uh who sold
us would be to respond to the fake news
the false information coming from Russia
I would like
all the media not just to be reporting
what Mr peshkov has to say but what the
spokesperson of the EU has to say and we
could do this in relatively short order
it shouldn't be costly it should be
fairly straightforward
it's just a question of choosing
the best man or the best woman for the
job and I think we should really address
this
address ourselves to this Tower straight
away of course with Mr Burrell so that
we can have an EU spokesperson
on the war in Ukraine thank you
thank you
I don't know who's best place to answer
that question Mr gelner I'm not saying I
need an answer I'm just launching an
idea and I hope it will you know find
its way through
thank you very much for that idea
on behalf of the green
thank you so much and thanks for this
great a great interesting inspiring and
inventive idea I think it's actually a
worth thinking about this and this is
basically this brings me uh to the point
that I wanted to say to to make
it's very comforting to mutually
reassure us that this is a problem and
I've heard enough colleagues saying this
what we need now are two things we need
resources and we need to discuss the
methods and the new Innovative tools
these are the only two issues because we
all agree that the misinformation is
there and those who don't agree they
spread misinformations themselves and
this is also something that I would like
uh to alert you but first
regarding some tools or questions that
we uh should discuss media access to
Russian public from outside we have very
good examples of rfe Radio free Europe
or Liberty they also share with us how
they are going about this I don't see a
European source which would be
comparable uh to that and that would
make an a concentrated effort to reach
out to those sources we have with
deutschevela and with others attempts to
do the same which are very good but we
have maybe to ask ourselves do we need
one I mean this is legitimate maybe we
don't uh but we should think about maybe
then a coordinated support for local uh
agencies on how to reach through vpns or
through mirror and Pages uh as uh others
uh uh do it uh reach to the Russian
public because this is going to be
um very important and this is important
number two using journalists who have
led to our countries and this is
something that I think we have two
weaknesses now number one we cannot
focus on one
issue now everyone is talking about
those who are not going to war and what
to do with them the real issue is what
to do with the dissidents and with the
journalists who come to us who have
always opposed this War and who are the
real instruments against this war that
we can use and who who are very uh who
are an asset uh to be honest and we
still don't have a humanitarian Visa
decision on European level we still have
only you know even in Germany and and I
applaud this we have been able to secure
this path and this channel but it is
still only 500 people who have been able
who we have been able to get out of the
country through this we mean we need
more and when we get them out then we
need to think about what we do with them
because uh there are there is support in
just yesterday has reestablished itself
as an entity novegazette is trying
unfortunately Mr morato was not there
Nova gazetto Europe is is here they are
doing good job but they should not at
least worry about what is going to
happen to them in one year or for some
people in three months when they have to
leave the European Union and still have
a problem with legalizing themselves
also in the Baltic states instead we're
talking there are two discussions one is
about about the War uh uh deniers which
is a totally different number and
totally different uh discussion and
another one is about closing the borders
for everyone instead of differentiating
and seeing that we have to work with
journalists and the other thing on how
to work with those journalists is not
just let them speak in Russian to the
Russian public in and outside Russia but
make the transfer of their positions
their perspectives their information
into the language of languages of our
country let's make a platform where they
will be provided with the Trans
translation with also the editorial uh
support where those people this great
asset can address in a concentrated
effort the people here because they have
the credibility that men any of our
journalists maybe for some of our
publics don't have
number three is what I already mentioned
I think that that we have not realized
that there will be a huge huge
confrontation and that it has already
taking place and this confrontation is
in informational so we need more
resources for the services of Mr aguna
but also for many many others and we
need to talk to talk about uh more tools
and finally we should not use the the
the floor where we're talking about
misinformation and and trying to uh
defeat disinformation by spreading this
information by our own members I mean
I'm very sorry but I didn't hear well Mr
church has already gone I haven't heard
much uh of people saying that uh Miss
Maloney is anti-russian what I heard is
that she is fascist and this is an
established fact I'm very sorry this is
a different piece of information so this
this was a total total disinformation
just as a very interesting way of
inserting and rejecting the
disinformation spread by Russians
regarding the environmental groups
supported we have to talk
you are deflecting from the topic that
is supposed to be discussed here about
the Russian misinformation instead you
are spreading it and the same with all
you know I love you dearly Claire but
what you've been saying is just total
rubbish because this is not the topic
that we're discussing here uh facts
about corruption everyone agrees that we
have a problem with corruption but what
does it have to do now with this
information uh uh offensive uh by the
Russian by the Russian side so I ask you
colleagues we are in a very serious
situation let's focus let's discuss
corruption in the Ukraine in other
office sessions about that and let's
discuss what is the biggest threat that
we're facing the threat of destabilizing
our democracy by Russian disinformation
here
I've seen that Mr Fest phone yes very
very briefly because you're ready
well as my name was mentioned Mr
lagodinski I have a different view of
course we have to talk about Russian
disinformation
but we shouldn't be blind on the left
side as it were and only react when uh
the disinformation seems to be coming
from the right wing so I would like us
to be more objective the European
Parliament is Duty bound to uncover all
disinformation and to criticize it and I
don't think we should depart from that
if that bothers you I I see I see that
but it's your problem I think we as
members of parliament have a duty to
report objectively on Russian
disinformation thank you sorry churches
and obviously I love Sergey too but the
only reason I brought up corruption was
because the bellingcat speaker brought
it up so
it's okay and of course I I will respond
that
any
this information any covert financing
any Uh Russian operations reporting this
or that group he has to be investigated
by this committee that's for sure but on
the topic of today it's obviously not
covert funding funding of any
organization be it even green
organizations it's it's the topic of
Russian disinformation campaign and how
it has an impact on our country's
support to uh Ukraine that is under full
aggression by the Russian Federation now
so that that's the topic of the day and
that's what the panelists are also
experts on
um
I'm going on uh Mr Wallace now for the
left
thank you very much Rafael
and first of all I would actually like
to agree with the German Deputy uh
Nicholas first that uh
objectivity uh is incredibly important
if we were to have any credibility
I want to ask about Omission as this
information
would you agree that the almost complete
lack of coverage of the anti-democratic
actions taken by the zelenski government
amounts to this information and
propaganda
Western leaders and media tell us that
Ukraine is fighting to defend democracy
from authoritarian Russia
we know that Russia is authoritarian and
that there is internal repression
increasingly so since the as the war
grinds on
Russia has been led by a right-wing
neoliberal nationalist
we also know zielinski has banned the
anti-war opposition parties ripped up
labor rights shut down media Outlets
while putting his country up for sale to
Western capital and institutions
instituting sweeping neoliberal reforms
that are be detrimental to ordinary
ukrainians
this reality is a far cry from the image
of Ukraine we are being sold
those who point this out who Vice
opposition to sanctions or the
continuation of the war
or highlight any other major
quantitation such as what he is like it
or not and NATO arming neo-nazis are
attacked in the Press put on lists
denounced as agents of the enemy
Western governments and media are not
only misinforming by excluding
inconvenient contexts from their
coverage vices with a different message
that are actively silenced sidelined and
maligned
this is not only a highly controlled
system of this information it is
authoritarianism
if we only focus on the messages that we
don't agree with we will learn nothing
as we facilitate the advance of
totalitarianism in Europe
is this not something that we should be
really worried about
thank you
thank you Mr petrula for the snd group
with a you have
thank you referral and thanks go to our
panelists of course it's a really hard
to say what is actually a worse Putin's
Invasion or accompanied Russian
narrative or its justification which
Echoes around there is of course clear
political agenda in Russia for years
uses this information propaganda cyber
attacks insights Regional tensions and
supports radical political options at
the same time a Russian aggression also
show us fresh and in a way Innovative
way to counter their this information as
a scene for example on social media my
questions are do Russia war against
Ukraine show a major upgrade in this
information or better resilience against
it how do we can generally evaluate EU
counter this information today
how significant is the for example New
Media Freedom Act and will its impact be
positive or negative finally I would
have a specific question regarding state
of playing one still unstable part of
Europe in our immediate neighborhood
which Kremlin is treating as its
playground
so we witnessed that the public
perception of the EU Across the Western
Balkans region almost everywhere is
declining in the light of these
circumstances how can European Union do
more to support Democratic political
forces civil society and the fact
Checkers in the fight against continuous
and the vicious Russian disinformation
there thank you
would like to add something but just
very briefly please
yes thank you chairman well I'd just
like to make a comment after what we
have heard
they comment I'd like to make is the
following yes it is true it is
absolutely true that in Ukraine like in
all countries that came out of Communism
that the economic policies that are
being applied are neoliberal it's true
that in many of the countries that came
out of Communism that the degree of
corruption is very high it is true Mr
Wallace above all that the degree of
corruption
is the highest by far in Russia
and that the level of
deregulation and the lack of control of
the economy is the highest well where is
it the highest in Russia not in Ukraine
so one final Point Mr Wallace during the
war the Second World War
did we have to talk about segregation in
the uh United States or British
colonialism or bombing in London and the
fight against Hitler so there is a
problem here when it comes to the
current situation yes of course there
was segregation in the USA and of course
it was a horrendous Scandal but should
we have had to play Down the battle and
the war against the Nazis because of
segregation in the United States and the
British colonies
please I mean I don't think that's what
you think
Mercy thank you very much
Mr Luker has a question because we need
questions to the panelists
okay thanks uh well I'm just replying to
the questions put to me
um listen I I don't think it's in our
interest uh to actually pretend that
things aren't great and and uh I
actually think that uh in any situation
in any of our situation we shouldn't
stop telling the truth because it suits
our position and with regard to Russia
right Russia uh is a hugely problematic
country very badly run and and and I I
would say that Putin has has stolen the
elections uh the last time round from
the Communist right uh I I I haven't
said a good word about Putin in my
lifetime right we haven't we have no
past on that type of a leader and but
what we're accused of being that Putin
uh purpose because we've been arguing
for peace diplomacy and negotiation we
are not mutant puppets we can't stand
them
uh okay okay so
now okay I am I'm sharing this committee
and I'm trying to make us focus on the
questions to our panelists
obviously one thing I can I can say
about your remarks is that
my country friends you have a big
variety of Medias including those who
are
spending their time on air criticizing
Ukrainian governments European help for
Ukraine and everything so the situation
is very different just about your
question the situation is very different
in our countries where you have
plurality of media including those who
break the mainstream line you will
qualify it while
this information coming from Russia is
coming from a country where
plurality of media was suppressed so
it's an official line that is special
sorry but in Ireland right uh dissenting
Vice is completely uh
we've only one narrative allowed in
Ireland today uh about the war one
narrative and any opposition to us is
absolutely uh completely but don't
reject your experience on everyone in
this Parliament
criticizing this line
and and I'm not sure uh Russians will be
in the same situation for sure but okay
we took the point now let's go back to
the panelists uh Mr Luke you have a
question
um
foreign
we need to look at ourselves very
critically because what the Kremlin is
doing well I can't decide that at the
end of the day I can't have any
influence on that so we have to look at
ourselves we have to do our own homework
so that's why I've got a question here
about quality quantity
where are we well prepared where can we
improve and then I have a second
question here
if we look at our own tool kit how full
is it
do we have things in our policies are
there things though do we have resources
are there resources that we don't want
to
um use for political will does that mean
the toolkit is empty or is it full is
there something we can actually use
thank you
thank you very much so I think that
question was for Mr Gunda and for our
panelists as well who so Mr gundu can
respond for the EAS so I have a question
and then I will give the floor to the
panelists
so we are going through a period which
is going to be a period of a social
unrest you've seen there is the energy
crisis there's inflation people are very
concerned
um and we can see from those concerns
that they're going to be exploited by
um Kremlin propagandists so have you
seen
in practice how those disinformation
networks are exploiting the energy
crisis and exploiting uh price Rises
have you seen uh that happen in a way
that can create instability which can
have a negative impact
and have you seen how that is working on
the social unrest which is Justified
which is leading people to condemn the
sanctions and questioning European
policy to support Ukraine have you seen
that in your work and now I will give
the floor to the panelists I would like
to thank them in advance for being
patient and listening to our debate
so thank you for being patient with our
debate because sometimes
um
we
um did have questions for you in the
middle of that debate as well I hope
you've noted them down so I'll give the
flow to Mr Sheldon first you have five
minutes
I'll uh I'll keep it brief um it is
nearly five in the morning on the U.S
east Coast I am incredibly tired and
hopefully I'll still make sense when I
talk
um so there's a lot of very good very
important questions that we've been
posed um through you know the past half
hour here
um
and I think a lot of them are probably
better suited for someone uh familiar
with you know strategic Communications
um that's obviously not my background I
did however want to uh touch on on one
point that was made about sort of me
allegedly incorrectly saying that
um you know Ukrainian or that there were
disinformation narratives about
um
uh westerns applied uh weapons reaching
the the black market
um from from Ukraine uh I I think that's
incorrect I I think it's either
misunderstood or or the statement was
made in bad faith
um because I I very clearly said that
it's a narrative
targeting specifically Western supplied
weapons
um very specifically and and its
individual instances that we have
analyzed evidence and found that either
it was insufficient or or appeared to be
fabricated
and so
for that reason I feel very comfortable
calling that this information and
and that's that's actually just about
what what I have um
to contribute I'm sorry that I don't
have better answers to uh to the other
questions
thank you very much
you can speak a bit longer
thank you and thank you for some some
really interesting uh interesting
perspectives some interesting questions
um I'll try and rattle through uh as
many as I can and forgive me because my
my note-taking is not uh not brilliant
um so at the start there was an
interesting question about how we can
Target disinformation
um that is focused on Russian audiences
so you know historically of course
Russians do not have a massive trust in
news obviously since um since uh the
Communist era um it just became a kind
of thing that they would know and you
know um there is a kind of uh an inbuilt
mistrust to official news in in Russia
but luckily a lot of especially the Next
Generation Russians are getting their
Newsroom Medusa are getting news from uh
independent Russian sources and we have
some brilliant Russian journalists often
who are operating
um at risk to their own safety uh
despite that are doing some brilliant
reporting and just to to link that um uh
one of the one of the questions from um
Mr lakadinski
um is spots on we have a brilliant
resource of people who have come from
Russia
um who are looking to help who have that
that contextual knowledge you have the
language who knows what channels
um most people are operating on whether
it's telegram whether it's um Facebook
Instagram is a big one uh in in
especially amongst the Next Generation
Um Russians so we need we do need to do
what we can to support them as as much
as possible but resources are huge a
huge Factor right like Medusa do
brilliant work but they are a tiny
organization who don't have a huge
amount of funding
um it's been mentioned that there could
be more that the European Parliament can
do to support or create even an
independent media channel to to to to do
that we did it very successfully during
the Cold War I don't quite understand
how in the information age it's not
easier to to do now
um
uh yes uh there was a good question Mr
Fest actually um about uh following the
money
um absolutely
um it's incredibly difficult we're not
an intelligence agency we have no links
to the intelligence Community
um it's very difficult for us to have
the resources to be able to see the
links between
um between organizations and Russia what
we can do and
um Mr chairman just to go back to one of
your earlier points
if we take a figure like for example
um uh as a far right figure I won't name
him because I don't want to get sued but
there is a far right figure in the UK um
who has a very popular telegram Channel
who parrots Russian disinformation
talking to a points he has about 200 000
followers mostly both based in the UK
some in the US
um he in 2018 went to Russia he posted
it on his own open social media he met
with people who we know to be involved
with the progression organization he met
with people known to be involved with
the far right and um posted photos with
them now we know that through open
source we know that he then parrots
Russian disinformation talking points
um we can't prove that he is a Russian
asset but there is enough there surely
for uh the European Parliament for this
committee for intelligence agencies or
law enforcement agencies across Europe
to be able to look at individuals like
that and look and examine and have that
resource to follow the money so I think
open source and journalism can be the
starting point the the
um uh you guys need to do the rest the
other thing I would say is when you have
do you have brilliant journalists like
Catherine Belton for example who wrote
that amazing book on uh you know on the
regime on the Putin regime and looked in
depth at some of the financial dealings
um she got sued and uh you know um
a terrible sort of Costa personal and
economic cost to herself there so as a
dis you know to and they do that
deliberately to make sure that
journalists don't go down the rabbit
hole and don't find those financial
leaks so we really do need institutional
support to to do that
um one of the one of the panelists uh uh
who uh mentioned about the Ukraine is
corrupt and infiltrated by Nina I mean
this is just I mean it's a brilliant
classic example of what about ISM
um uh just as I mentioned in my opening
remarks I mean there are Nazis in the UK
um
they don't have any influence
um and uh I did just while you were
speaking I did a quick uh Google on um
uh procurement corruption and Ireland
and uh got a number of different hits
Ireland isn't corrupt like it's it's
it's kind of absurd and uh Mr Wallace um
an independent poll conducted in August
by Ira uh put zielinski's job approval
at 91 that's an independent poll so um
that's what happens in democracy we
don't always agree with what a
government does but um that's democracy
um what else
I think that's it oh and on the the
um on the last comment about research uh
the food and energy Etc so we did some
research um a couple of uh weeks ago we
looked at the outputs from Russian
um uh Embassy social media accounts for
the last six months uh to track
narratives across time
um every single account that we tracked
and mostly we were looking at Global
South countries so in Latin America
um uh southeast Asia and sub-Saharan
Africa
um every single one of those Embassy
accounts
um were uh posting about uh energy
security about food security and how is
default of of the West
um and a lot of those accounts have been
Amplified and sort of uh put on on
telegram Etc so
um it is one of their kind of big
narratives as the as the situation gets
worse we can expect it to to be
Amplified
um that you know as the winter starts to
bite
um that it is our fault effectively that
it's Ukraine's fault it's the West's
fault for for interfering this you can
you can completely
um see that happening and just to go
back lastly um to to an earlier uh
question about
um
resilience
so they're nothing if not predictable
right we know what narratives they're
going to be deploying we know where
they're going to be deploying the
narratives it's often in countries which
don't have the um the strong independent
media sector who don't have a good
um uh established legislative bodies who
can protect civil society and don't have
a strong Civil Society sector
um
so we know where they're going to be
targeting and what we can do what you
guys can do as a European Parliament is
work with host governments and to build
resilience against against that you can
work with ngos who work in communities
who we know are going to be targeted by
Russian disinformation to pre-bunk to
tell them what's coming down the line to
introduce them to Independent Media
sources where they can get objective
news rather than being going to what's
salacious and easy which is often what
uh russian-backed media are doing so
um there are there are good things that
we can do um I'd be happy to talk to
anybody in more detail about about those
things but um thank you very much very
much for having me uh and yeah look
forward to more of the debate thank you
foreign
now I'm turning into Mr grunder uh Chef
de la division of communication
strategic
power you have
and you
can for longer than the time
times most of the questions
were
virtually forward
for internal Action Service so maybe you
might know uh who that spokesperson
could be that Mr getter is looking for
difficult situation here
um and it's also not so easy to
intervene after two excellent panelists
but let me try maybe to summarize it in
in three blocks what I want to say the
first one is maybe come back to the
issue of the nature of the threat I
think this is something so fundamental
to to understand to be able to design
our responses as well the second is to
give you just a snapshot of some of the
activities that we're doing some of the
new activities as well and the third one
is maybe some thoughts on the on the way
forward
so um I think it's important not to put
the issue of disinformation in the box
of this is a communication challenge
there's a narrative out there and we
just need to develop our narrative and
then we have solved the problem
the the problem is much deeper because
the information environment is being
used the manipulation of the entire
information environment as a strategic
tool and if we don't understand this
holistic way that this is also about
influencing media that this is about
even using other parts of the toolbox
cyber attacks and other things and if we
just doctor at the little kind of
narrative at the little part of the
disinformation then it will be difficult
to to find good good Solutions so the
challenge is very
um is very multifaceted and I think
these Revelations of EU design for lab
and of meta Facebook just happening two
days ago show us the complexity and the
sophistication of these activities and I
come back we will not be able just to
counter this with uh with a bit of
better communication here and there the
issue is asymmetrical
asymmetrical in the sense that we are
targeted by means that we don't want to
use I don't think anybody here in this
room wants to use this information as a
counter as a counter means nobody wants
to kind of use cyber attacks from our
side so we need to be more intelligent
in in finding our
responses and that is of course not not
very easy but if we don't understand the
Strategic nature of these attacks and we
have seen it now since uh the 24th of
February that the entire spectrum is
being used from state-controlled media
to a very bizarre Gray Zone of websites
some of them linked to Security Services
down to undercover operations in social
media so if we don't understand that I
think that is difficult to to respond
now
um a lot has been done but of course a
lot still needs to be done because the
challenge is so so massive and of course
this is also a question of resources
my job and the job of the es is to to do
the best we can with the resources that
we have
and we have been doing this in trying to
design also this this response in the
best way possible in kind of also
distinguishing what needs to be done in
terms of situational awareness in
resilience and capacity building in
disruption and regulation also and last
but not least also to deploy our foreign
policy tools that we have and I think I
think this debate that we had already on
sanctions or other tools that impose
costs on disinformation actors is
exactly what needs to be done I will not
give you the full list of everything
that we are doing here we don't have the
time and that's also not the the place
to do this but I just want to underline
that kind of we have massively increased
our activities and Outreach to
journalists
um to the to the broader media to raise
awareness and not only inside the EU
also outside the EU in the neighborhood
in particular
we have a very good tool it's not not
enough of course but it's a it's a good
good tool it's the EO versus this intro
which has now two million visitors since
the 24th of uh of February so there is a
multiplying effect there isn't an effect
that we are reaching but again it will
not be enough we need more we have
equipped the member states also with
very concrete
lists of disinformation narratives
possible debunks we have strengthened
our delegations in that field we have
raised support for for the media
capacity building very very important
was just mentioned I think by one of you
we have also done my team even Hands-On
training of fact Checkers of the Eastern
partnership region etc etc but this is
not to say that everything is under
control it's just that we use these
resources the best we can but it is a
question of resources
um and in our own work uh just to answer
your question Mr chairman of course we
have seen that these issues related to
energy energy supplies
um have been massively uh used we have
documented them on uh on EU versus this
info very publicly and I think many
other organizations have done this
now a little bit on the on the way
forward also for for you here in uh in
all the three committees that are that
are present I think it's clear that
there's no Silver Bullet there's no easy
one kind of initiative that will solve
everything and we have discussed this
together over the past two years
um in in many of the of the discussions
but I think there are a few kind of
additional things that that can be
considered and one also concerns the
communication part as Viola from Carmen
has has said we need to further invest
in this the es has relatively limited uh
resources in that field we have an idea
I think it was discussed with some of
the members also in in Alfred to build
stronger communication hubs also
Regional ones this is something that we
need to to discuss also with you
um because this will require support
from this house
we also need to strengthen further kind
of the the abilities not only of my team
but also of others to detect to analyze
to react to this information
manipulation which comes in in so many
different forms and shapes and I think
what is important here is not only to
look at the European level but also to
see how can we connect the member states
in in all this there is a bit of a
missing link and that should go beyond
the rapid alert system that exists
already and coming back to to my first
point we need to have a capability not
only to react to foreign information
manipulation so strategic Communications
but we really need to create an ability
that allows us to react to foreign
interference forms countering foreign
interference I think is is very
important last but not least Civil
Society needs the support also from this
house there are very few kind of
possibilities that they can use in terms
of funding
um I think this is another another Point
I've been a little bit long but thank
you very much also for the support that
we had here
Mr Gunner you you have not you have not
been wrong and Mr vashikovski when I'm
from and myself will just have
small small comments and Mr vashikovski
please
thank you Mr chairman um
I'm not disappointed by the outcome of
this debate because I didn't have any
optimistic expectations
uh for we don't have uh common answer to
Russian trolls for many reasons the
first is I would say tourism first
reason is because we still have no
common evaluation of a Russian
aggression
some leaders are still calling Putin
thinking in a naive way that forced him
to resign from war but calling him they
are legitimizing he maxi
some other listeners
voting in the parliament yesterday to
block delivery of weapon to Ukraine the
same day when Russians are blowing
in the Baltic Sea infrastructure
so that's one reason the second reason
is even deeper
because we have internal conflict here
in European Union we have a still
debate or battle between majority of
liberal left
politician institution against
conservative governments and politicians
and I think that majority of you think
that
the leaders in Hungary Poland and now in
Rome a bigger threat than Putin and
that's why you have a common house how
to stop Russian aggression thank you
uh I don't think that anybody here
thinks that these governments are bigger
threat than Putin even if one that you
named can be seen sometimes as a Troian
horse of putting one
um
Mr magellino please you have the floor
thank you so it's very interesting what
we've heard this morning in the debate
and we have different opinions of course
but I'd have a request for the chair
and I'll make this request in the
coordinators as well
a few weeks ago
we got news on the media in Italy and
elsewhere
about
an information package from the USA on
the relationship between Putin and
European politicians
I think we need to do everything we can
to get that kind of information
so that we could have an objective
basis
so it wouldn't be us who would be trying
to
reconstruct this network of
relationships with a few various
different ideas
and looking at what's happening with
politicians in Europe
so I think
there have been a range of packages of
information from the USA and I think we
need to get them immediately
and then the EU institutions need to be
able to respond in a much more
determined way than they have until now
thank you great just for your
information we already initiated the
dimash to the American embassy
uh for them to deliver to the committee
more specific information of course
but we should continue and push for this
and it should not be saved like that and
then everybody forgets about that
Madame Von Carmen
just very quickly because some things
were mentioned by by Mr Gunner which I
think we really should
specify a little bit what we mean with
that and also how maybe the European
Parliament can support you in this but
one more remark uh towards my respected
share of the Ukraine delegation I fully
understand and I fully share your
concern when it comes to calling of
Putin but sometimes you know the
information for example that the
bundestag was blocking weapons delivery
is false I don't know who spread this
but there was no vote in the bundle
stack and everyone is circling around
the bundestock was blocking weapon
deliveries but there was no vote in the
bundlestack so I have asked my
colleagues and sometimes it's also
helpful if the false information gets
not or does not get spread around even
by us so please also consider this thing
two two or three points on what Mr
Gunner has said first of all
um our foreign minister for example used
the annual assembly of all the diplomats
to tell them that fighting
misinformation fighting death
information fighting propaganda from
Russia is a mainstream in the German
Diplomatic Corps has Mr Burrell ever
done that is it a mainstream issue has
he has he really given this instruction
to all the diplomats is there a
coordination point in all the delegation
is somebody dealing with this do they
know how to debunk that because what
I've seen is randomly yes we have some
good diplomats and I have I was
following this for example in South
Africa and others but this is randomly
there is nobody taking over this
initiative there's nobody debunking it
there's nobody reaching out on a regular
systematic level from our delegation
nobody has a clue how to do this if this
is a led a lack of finances and the
European Parliament should put more in
the in the budget Sega lagodinski Mr
Gala and others are probably the best
ones who would uh who would fight for
this but what I've heard so far is a
little bit of capacity building a little
bit working together with the delegation
is not sufficient and we are talking
about this already for quite some time
and I've not seen that they was taken
over as a mainstream issue for the
diplomats in our delegations
thank you and then I'm closing the
speaking list in a very authoritarian
manner
uh uh um and I'm starting with Madame
luazo and then Mr lagodinski and then
myself as a chair I'm also appointing me
to speak
thank you chair
um I would like to fully support what uh
Mr margarino said about the importance
of knowing more about
um uh Russian financing of political
parties in Europe it's too easy to uh
finger point uh the greens or uh if our
right or the far left when you are from
a different political party where it
would really make a difference if we
know more about who including among the
political parties represented in the
European Parliament had Financial
relations with Russia because it makes a
whole difference our Parliament has this
amazing asset of freedom of speech
freedom of expression freedom of opinion
and we cherish it and we have to protect
it but we have to be a fully
convinced that some are using it in
order to spread this information and
and sometimes they don't cherish the
same freedom of opinion at home I
remember vividly that an Irish
journalist is facing a slapping
procedure in Ireland just because she
worked on uh some speeches and some
statements of one of her colleagues so I
would just like to stress that not
everything is equal and you cannot put
forward freedom of expression in the
European Parliament and then fight
against it at home I would also react to
um what Luke gilner said and support
what Viola from Carmen also stated
I'm not convinced at all that our EU
delegations abroad are doing the right
thing in terms of strategic
communication I travel a lot I have a
lot of talks and yes there are good
people because they have some knowledge
they have some experience and they
decide to communicate but now that there
is a diplomatic Academy this should be a
a systematic training there should be
systematic
instructions sent to our delegations
abroad it doesn't cost a euro to do this
it's just a question of good
organization of and of prioritization of
our work and let's face it we are not
doing it enough right now
yes thank you and I just wanted to
follow up on actually what Madame lozo
uh just said I do agree that we cannot
expect and we should not you know go low
when the other side goes low so it's not
about this information but what is
lacking I think is the understanding
also among diplomatic services that this
is part of the new portfolio of
diplomacy that communication diplomacy
means also
um being more offensive you know in a
positive way
going after that and also yes countering
uh not distance from disinformation but
counter-information what is being spread
and I think this is something that has
to change and this this change can only
come from the top either from analena in
Germany or from Mr Burrell here or from
from the line uh even if the president
from the line here and that's important
communication diplomacy as part of the
new new package of tools and just very
briefly to react to colleague
the chair
um I do think that there is a point
there there is a division that does not
help us encountering the real threat
this division goes both ways it's not
just from our side or from your side but
I do think that what we're lacking and
this would be a proposal here is a a
platform where we would sit together and
talk I don't think that the the
Hungarian governing colleagues should be
part of it because they're a lost cause
but I think that in in terms of
communication with our polish colleagues
we only communicate when we do
resolutions and negotiate resolutions in
a positive way every everything else is
just scolding at each other we need a
safe space where we sit down and we talk
because what we're facing now is a much
larger threat than everything else and
we will not you will not convince us to
stop our criticism system we will not
convince you to stop ocaries but we need
to talk to each other and to channel
this energy in a productive
geopolitically productive way
yes
and this is quite important
um Mia I have a very quick question uh
you mentioned several time resources
and I fully share your point of view
can you just tell the members how many
you are and uh no yes I think it's
important to be basic
yeah how big is your team and what are
your resources because it's it's
important for us to understand and
especially for those who don't follow
this uh file for for the last two years
uh to understand
I mean how much resource we put in this
fight for our democracy and then the
second point is
what do you uh I mean I know you cannot
respond to us but I need to ask a
question uh what do you expect
from your point of view
of this packed for the defense of
democracy we were all very happy I guess
that Madame Van Der Lyon president of
the commission came to the Parliament
and announced this because it's fitting
obviously the agenda of this committee
from the very start but what will be
your take on on
being at the center of the defense of
democracy with your team for the for
months and months so
how we could improve that your situation
and insert it in the back
I hope you have a lot of time because I
have a lot of ideas but don't worry
um no in all I mean this is all public
knowledge that's why my team and some of
my my kind of colleagues are here
um is composed of 41 staff we're dealing
with the Eastern partnership the Western
Balkans the Mediterranean which are the
priority regions we have created a
specific team that can deal with issues
related to the Far East
with support of this of this house in
particular we have created a team of
four that is dealing with specifically
our missions and operations who come
more and more under Threat by these uh
interference and uh and information
manipulation activities we have a team
that is dealing with all this Outreach
also not only in the member states but
also with many many of our partners and
I can give you many more details but
it's 41 people in terms of Financial
Resources
um specifically for this part the
Strategic Communications also reacting
to foreign information manipulation not
only in the EU but also with Partners we
have at the moment 11 million euros a
lot of the money needs to be invested in
our ability to detect actually what's
going on that is expensive it doesn't
come at zero
and I let you kind of compare this to
other to other initiatives I just put it
out as a as a as a general point this is
not just the the decision of the high
representative who supports this very
very much it is also a question of the
budgetary authority how many resources
we have our at our disposal and maybe
since I have the the floor also to
respond also to your second question but
maybe also to say something about the
comment by Viola from Carmen we have the
uh the annual ambassadors conference
coming up and I think you will also be
involved when all the ambassadors are
here they will hear this from the boss
and you should also tell them very very
clearly this is uh we have also in our
internal discussions we have put this a
very very important element because it's
not only resources also a a mindset
issue it's a competence issue it's a
know-how issue and believe me my team
and all of them uh here and and who are
not here kind of this is our task also
this capacity building of our own
structures connecting this to the member
states and connecting it to Partners I
know sometimes it looks disappointing
but uh believe us we work 200 of our
time
um the other question about the package
I would turn to the commission
colleagues but they are not here um
because actually I don't know all the
details I personally are from the view
of the external Action Service we of
course uh believe that this is an
excellent initiative because we need to
think broader I think you have mentioned
it we need to understand the money flows
we need to understand what other kind of
information sorry interference kind of
routes are being taken so I think that
will help raising awareness it will also
create hopefully kind of tangible uh
instruments I think a lot can be done on
the level of transparent see but I don't
want to comment for the colleagues of
the of the European commission who will
be dealing with this also in the more
legal kind of aspects I hope that gives
you some insights from my side
thank you
colleagues
that brings that point on the agenda to
a close we're going to have a
10 minute break now no more than that
because
our next item is an exchange of views
with Audrey Tang who's the minister of
digital Affairs in Taiwan
and she will be responding to our
questions and I would like to encourage
you to attend that exchange of views
because it will answer many questions
that have been
asked this in this session
obviously Taiwan is a democracy which
has suffered an unprecedented
disinformation campaign and in